[Musique]
ici on est à poissy à la ferme
biologique de normandie ou 18 rue des
capucines on est producteur la ferme
biologique de normandie ont fait de la
viande en bio depuis trois générations
sur la ferme
pionnier en agriculture biologique le
respect du bien-être de l'animal
et de la bonne viande qu'on fait et on
arrive en fin d'année 2021 les bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année en famille enfin
donc voilà les premiers produits phares
de la ferme biologique de normandie un
beau chapeau à déguster en famille
pommes de terre pruneaux marron voilà
efficace et rapide voilà est autrement
on a également pour les familles plus
petit le rôti de dinde sa fille aux
pruneaux d'énerver avec une bonne farce
de vaud à l'intérieur nourries à l'herbe
voilà voilà en plein air à déguster
pareil avec tonnes de terre oignons
pruneaux marron voilà une bonne
dégustation des produits de la ferme
biologique de normandie